This answer here, that the profile stores conference
names not keys, is wrong. We do store the
conference keys. However, we store them as strings.
So, this answer is correct. The profile stores the
conference keys as strings. So because they're strings,
we have to convert them into keys, before we
can use the key to load the entity from
the data store. The reason that we use strings
for the keys, is that you can't parse actual key entities
around inside of JSON. So we create a web safe version
of the key as a string. And this answer is wrong.
Yeah, I know, it would be, it would be nice just to
simply return the value of the property, but it's not going to
work. So you can find the finished code for getConferencesToAttend in
the lesson four folder, if you need a bit of help
writing the code. So go take a look if you need to.